The following is a
conversation with Kyle vote.
He's the president and the CTO of cruise
automation leading an effort to solve
one of the biggest robotics challenges
of our time vehicle automation.
He's a co founder of two
successful companies,
twitch and crews that have
east sold for $1 billion.
And he's a great example of the innovative
spirit that flourishes in Silicon
Valley.
And now it's facing an interesting and
exciting challenge of matching that
spirit with the mass production and
the safety century culture of a major
automaker like General Motors.
This conversation as part of the MIT
artificial general intelligence series and
the artificial intelligence podcasts.
If you enjoy it,
please subscribe on Youtube,
iTunes,
or simply connect with me on Twitter
at Lex Friedman, spelled f, r I. D.
And now here's my
conversation with Kyle vote.
You grew up in Kansas, right? Yeah. And I
just saw that picture you had to hit. No,
there's some a little bit, a little
bit worried about that now. Yeah.
So in high school in Kansas City,
you joined Shawnee mission north
high school robotics team. Yeah.
Now that wasn't your high school.
That's right. That was, that was, uh,
the only high school in the
area that had a, like a,
a teacher who was willing to
sponsor our first robotics team.
I was going to troll you a little bit,
jog your memory a little bit. Yeah,
that kid trying to look super cool
and intent. It does, cause you know,
this was battlebots
it's a serious business.
So we're standing there with a welded
steel frame and look and tough.
So go back there. What does
that jury to robotics? Well,
I think I, I've been trying
to figure this out for awhile,
but I've always liked building things
with legos and when I was really,
really young, I wanted the
Legos. I had motors and other
things and then, you know,
Lego Mindstorms came out and for the
first time you could program Lego
contraptions. And I think, uh, things
just sort of snowballed from that.
But I remember, um, seeing, you know,
the battlebots TV show on comedy central
and thinking that is the coolest thing
in the world. I want to be
a part of that. And, uh,
not knowing a whole lot about how to
build these 200 pound fighting robots.
So I sort of obsessive
Lee poured over the, uh,
Internet forums where all the creators
for battlebots would sort of hang out and
talk about, you know, document their
build progress and everything. And, uh,
I think I read, I must
have read like, you know,
tens of thousands of foreign posts from
basically everything that was out there
on what these people were doing and
eventually like sort of triangulate it how
to, how to put some of these
things together and, and uh, uh,
ended up doing battlebots, which
was, you know, I was like 13 or 14,
which was pretty awesome.
I'm not sure if the show is still running,
but so battlebots is, there's not an
artificial intelligence component.
It's remotely controlled and you're,
it's almost like a mechanical
engineering challenge of yeah,
I think things that can be broken
there, radio controlled. So, uh,
and I think that they allowed some
limited form of autonomy, but you know,
in a two minute match your you're
in and the way these things ran,
you're doing yourself a disservice
by trying to automate it versus just,
you know, do the practical thing,
which is drive it yourself.
And there's an entertainment aspect,
uh, just just going, I need to,
but there's like, some of them wield an
ax, some of them, I mean there's that fun.
So what drew you to that ass but it
wasn't the mechanical engineering.
Was it the dream to create
like a Frankenstein and
tell essentially and being,
or was it just like the Lego, you like
tinkering with stuff? I mean that,
that was just
building something. I think
the idea of, you know, this,
this radio controlled machine that,
that can do various things if it has
like a weapon or something was pretty
interesting. I agree. It's, it doesn't
have the same appeal as, you know,
autonomous robots, which I, which I, you
know, sort of gravitated towards later on.
But it was definitely an engineering
challenge because everything you did in
that competition was pushing
components to their limits.
So we would buy like these $40
DC motors that came out of a,
a winch like on the front of a pickup
truck or something and we power their car
with those and we'd run them at like
double or triple their rated voltage so
they immediately start overheating.
But for that two minute match,
you can get a significant increase in
the power output of those motors before
they burn out. And so you're doing
the same thing for your battery packs.
All the materials and the
system. And I think there is
something, something, uh, uh,
intrinsically interesting about just
seeing like where things break and
did you offline see where they break?
Did you take it to the test stand point?
Like how did you know the two minutes or
was there a reckless let's just go with
it and see.
We weren't very good at battlebots. We
lost all of our matches the first round,
the one I built first,
both of them were these wedge
shaped robots cause of wedge.
Even though it's sort of boring
and look at is extremely effective.
You'd drive towards another robot and
the front edge of it gets under him.
And then they sort of flip over,
kinda like a door stopper.
And the first one had a pneumatic polished
stainless steel spike on the front
that would shoot out about eight inches.
The purpose of which is what
pretty pretty ineffective actually,
but it looks cool. And uh, it was,
it helped with the lift. No it was,
it was just to try to poke holes
in the other robot. And then, uh,
the second time I did it,
which is the following,
I think maybe 18 months later we had a,
well a titanium acts with a,
with a hardened steel tip on it that
was powered by a hydraulic cylinder,
which we were a activating
with liquid co two,
which was, had its own
set of problems. So great.
So that's kind of on the
hardware side. I mean, uh,
at a certain point there must have been
born or fascination on the software
side. So what was the first piece of
code you've written? A man go back there.
See what language was it? What a, what
was the, was the emacs vim, was it a,
a more respectable modern id?
Do you remember any of this?
Yeah, well I remember, um,
I think maybe when I was in
third or fourth grade school,
I was at elementary school,
had a bunch of apple,
two computers and we'd play games on those
and I every once in a while something
would, would uh, would crash.
It wouldn't start up correctly
and it would dump you out too.
What I later learned was like sort of a
command prompt and my teacher would come
over and type actually remember
this to this day for some reason,
like PR number six or PR pound six,
which is peripheral six,
which is the disk drive, which is
fire up the disk and load the program.
And I just remember thinking, wow, she's
like a hacker. Like teach me these,
these codes, these error codes. This
is what I called them at the time.
But she had no interest in that.
So it wasn't until I think about fifth
grade that I had a a a school where you
could actually go on these
apple twos and learn to program.
And so there's all in basic,
you know, where every line,
you know the line numbers
are all numb or the,
every line is numbered and you have
to like leave enough space between the
numbers so that if you want to tweak
your code, you go back and it's,
the first line was 10 in the second
line is 20 now you have to go back and
insert 15 and if you need to add
code in front of that, you know,
11 or 12 and you hope you don't run out
of line numbers and have to Redo the
whole thing. There's go to statements.
Yeah. Goto and is very basic.
Maybe hence the name. But
yeah, a lot of fun. And that
was like, that was, you know,
that's when, that's when you know, when
you first program you see the magic of it.
It's like,
it just like this world opens up with
endless possibilities for the things you
could build or,
or accomplish with that computer.
So you got the bug then.
So even started with basic and then what
c plus plus throughout, uh, what did you,
was there a computer programming,
computer science classes in high school?
Not, not where I went. So it
was self taught, but I did
a lot of programming. Right.
The thing that
you know,
sort of pushed me in the path of
eventually working on self driving cars is
actually one of these really long trips
driving from my house in Kansas to uh,
uh, to I think Las Vegas where we
did the battlebots competition.
And I had just gotten my,
I think my learner's permit
or early driver's permit.
And so I was driving this,
you know,
10 hour stretch across western
Kansas where it's just,
you're going straight on a highway
and it is mind numbingly boring.
And I remember thinking even then
with my sort of mediocre programming
background that this is something
that a computer can do. Right?
Let's take a picture of the road and
let's find the yellow lane markers and you
know, steer the wheel. And you know, later
I'd come to realize this had been done,
you know, since, since the eighties
or the seventies or even earlier,
but I still wanted to do it.
And sort of immediately after that trip
switched from sort of battlebots which
is more radio controlled machines too.
Think about building,
you know,
autonomous vehicles of some scale.
Start off with really small
electric ones and then, you know,
progressed to what we're doing now.
So what was your view of artificial
intelligence at that point? What,
what did you think?
So this is a,
before there's been ways in artificial
intelligence, right? Uh, the,
the current wave with deep learning makes
people believe that you can solve in a
really rich deep way the computer
vision perception problem.
But like in a,
before the deep learning craze,
you know,
how do you think about,
how would you even go about
building a thing that perceives
itself in the world, localize itself
in the world, moves around the world.
Like when you were younger,
what was your thinking about it?
Well, prior to deep neural networks
are accomplished, all known it,
New Orleans modern techniques we have
or at least ones that are in use today.
It was all a heuristic space and so like
old school image processing and I think
a extracting,
you know,
yellow lane markers out of an image of
a road is one of the problems that lends
itself reasonably well to
those heuristic based methods.
You know like just do a threshold on the
color yellow and then try to fit some
lines to that using a half transform
or something and then go from there.
Traffic, light detection and then stop
signs detection, red, yellow, green.
And I think you can, you could, I
mean if you wanted to do a full, it's,
I was just trying to make something that
would stay in between the lanes on a
highway.
But if you wanted to do the full,
the full set of capabilities needed for
a driverless car, I think you could,
and we'd done this at cruise.
You know,
in the very first days you can start
off with a really simple, you know,
human written heuristic just to get the
scaffolding in place for your system.
Traffic, light detection, probably
a really simple, you know,
color thresholding on day one just to
get the system up and running before you
migrate to, you know, a deep learning
based technique or something else.
And you know, back in, when I
was doing this, my first one,
it was on a pentium 203 233
megahertz computer in it. And I,
I think I wrote the
first version in basic,
which is like an interpreted language.
It's extremely slow cause that's
the thing I knew at the time.
And so there was no, no chance
at all of using, there was no,
no computational power to do any sort
of reasonable deep nets like you have
today. So, I don't know what kids these
days are doing. Our kids these days,
you know, at age 13, using neural
networks in their garage. I mean,
that would be awesome.
I get emails all the time from, you
know, like 11, 12 year olds saying,
I'm having,
you know,
I'm trying to follow this tends of flood
tutorial and I'm having this problem.
And their general approach in the deep
learning community is of extreme optimism
of, as opposed to, you mentioned
like heuristics. You can, you can,
you can separate the
autonomous driving problem,
two modules and try to
solve it sort of rigorously,
or you can just do it end to end.
And most people just kind of
love the idea that, you know,
all us humans do it end to end.
We just perceive and act.
We should be able to use that,
uh,
do the same kind of thing when you're
on that and that, that kind of thinking,
you don't want to criticize that kind of
thinking because eventually there will
be, right. Yeah.
And so it's exciting and especially when
they're younger to explore that as a
really exciting approach. But
yeah, it's, it's changed. Uh, the,
the language, the kind of
stuff you're tinkering with it.
It's kind of exciting to see
when these teenagers grow up.
Yeah.
I can only imagine if you,
if your starting point is python and
tensor flow at age 13 where you end up,
you know,
after 10 or 15 years of that,
that's pretty cool because a get hub,
because the stair tools for solving
most of the major problems in artificial
intelligence are within a few lines of
code for most kids.
And that's incredible to think about also
on the entrepreneurial side. And, and,
and at that point,
was there any thought about
entrepreneurship before
you came to college is sort
of doing years of building this into a
thing that impacts the world on a large
scale?
Yeah, I've always wanted to start a
company. I think that's, you know,
just a cool concept of creating
something and exchanging it for value or
creating value I guess. So in high
school I was, I was trying to build like,
you know,
a servo motor drivers,
little circuit boards and sell them
online or are there other things like that
and certainly knew at some
point I wanted to do a startup,
but it wasn't really a, I'd say until
college, until I felt like I had the,
I guess the right combination
of the environment,
the smart people around you and uh, some
free time and a lot of free time at Mit.
So you came to MIT as an
Undergrad, 2004. That's right.
And that's when the first Darpa
grand challenge was happening. Yeah.
The timing of that is
a beautifully poetic,
so how'd you get yourself
involved in that one?
Originally there wasn't a official
injury. Yeah. Faculty sponsored thing.
And so a bunch of undergrads,
myself included,
started meeting and got
together and tried to, to, uh,
Hagel together some sponsorships.
We've got a vehicle,
donated a bunch of sensors and
try to put something together.
And so we had our team was probably
mostly freshmen and sophomores, you know,
which, which was not really a fair, fair
fight against maybe the, uh, you know,
postdoc and faculty led teams
from other schools. But we, uh,
we got something up and running. We had
our vehicle drive by wire and you know,
very, very basic control
and things. But, uh,
on the day of the qualifying
prequalifying round,
the one and only steering motor that we
had purchased, the thing that we had,
you know, retrofitted to turn the
steering wheel on the truck died.
And so our vehicle was just dead
in the water, couldn't steer.
So we didn't make it very far
and the hardware side. So was there
a software component? Was there,
like how did your view of autonomous
vehicles in terms of artificial
intelligence, right, evolve in
those moment? I mean, you know,
like you said from the 80s
has been autonomous vehicles,
but really that was the birth
of the modern wave, the,
the thing that captivated everyone's
imagination that we can actually do this.
So how were you captivated
in that way? We, so, well,
how did your view of a
vehicles change at that point?
Um, I'd say at that point
in time it was, it was a
curiosity as in like,
is this really possible?
And I think that was generally the spirit
and the purpose of that original Darpa
grand challenge,
which was to just get a whole bunch of
really brilliant people exploring this
space and pushing the limits.
And I think like to day that
Darpa challenge with it's
$1 million prize pool was
probably one of the most effective,
you know, uses of taxpayer money,
dollar for dollar that I've
seen, you know, because that,
that small sort of initiative
that Darfa put, uh,
put out sort of in my view was the
catalyst or the tipping point for this,
this whole next wave of autonomous vehicle
development. So that was pretty cool.
So let me jump around a
little bit on that point,
they also did the urban challenge
where it was in the city,
but it was very artificial and there's
no pedestrians and there's very little
human involvement except the a
few professional drivers. Yeah.
Do you think there's room and then
there was the robotics challenge with
humanoid robots, right? In your
now role is looking at this,
you're trying to solve one of the
autonomous driving, one of the harder,
more difficult places,
San Francisco.
Is there a role for Darpa to step in to
also kind of help out big challenge with
new ideas,
specifically a pedestrians and so on,
all these kinds of interesting things?
Well I haven't, I haven't thought
about it from that perspective.
Is there anything Darpa could do
today to further accelerate things?
And I would say my instinct is that that's
maybe not the highest and best use of
their resources and time because like
kickstarting and spinning up the flywheel
is I think what, what they did in this
case for a very, very little money.
But today this has become,
this has become like commercially
interesting to very large companies in the
amount of money going into it.
And the amount of people like you going
through your class and learning about
these things and developing
his skills is just, you know,
orders of magnitude more
than it was back then.
And so there's enough momentum and
inertia and energy and investment dollars
into this space right now that, uh, I
don't, I don't, um, I think they're,
I think they can just say mission
accomplished and move on to the next.
That's an area of technology that,
that needs help.
So then stepping back to MIT, he
left them it junior, junior year.
What was that decision like?
As I said,
I always wanted to do a company in a,
or start a company and this
opportunity landed in my lap,
which was a couple guys from Yale,
a,
we're starting a new company and I googled
them and found that they had started
a company previously and sold it actually
on Ebay for about a quarter million
bucks, which was pretty interesting
story. But, so I thought to myself,
these guys are, you know, rock star
entrepreneurs, they've done this before.
They must be driving around in Ferrari's
cause they sold their company. And uh,
you know,
I thought I could learn a lot from him.
So I teamed up with those guys
and you know, went out during,
went out to California during IAP,
which is MIT's a month off,
a on one on one way ticket
and basically never went back.
We were having so much fun.
We felt like we were building something
and creating something and it was going
to be interesting. You
know, I was just all in and,
and got completely hooked and
that that business was Justin TV,
which is originally a reality
show about a guy named Justin,
which morphed into a live
video streaming platform,
which then morphed into what
is twitch today. So that was,
that was quite a and unexpected journey.
So
no regrets? No. Looking back it
was just an obvious one way ticket.
I mean if we just pause on that
for a second. There was no,
how did you know these were the right
guys, this is the right decision.
You didn't think it was just
follow the heart kind of thing.
Well I didn't know.
But you know,
just trying something for a month during
IAP seems pretty low risk. Right, right.
And then, you know, well maybe
I'll take a semester off.
Mit's pretty flexible about that.
You can always go back. Right.
And then after two or three
cycles of that, I eventually
threw in the towel. But,
uh, you know, I think it's, um,
I guess in that case I felt like I could
always hit the undo button if I had to.
Right. But it nevertheless, from
a, when you look in retrospect,
I mean it seems like a brave decision
that, you know, as difficult,
it would be difficult for a lot of
people to make it, it wasn't as popular.
I'd say that the general,
you know,
flux of people out of MIT at the time
it was mostly into finance or consulting
jobs in Boston or New York.
And very few people were going
to California to start companies.
But today I'd say that's
probably inverted,
which is just a sign of a
sign of the times, I guess.
Yep.
So there's a story about
midnight of March 18 2007 where,
uh,
whether we're a tech crunch,
I guess announced Justin TV earlier
than it was supposed to, a few hours.
The site didn't work.
I don't know if any of this is true.
You can tell me and a u and w w one of
the folks adjusted t Emmett shear coded
through the night. Can you take me
through that experience? So let me,
let me say a few nice things
that, uh, the art card,
red quoted a Justin Kahn said that you
were known for bureau coding through
problems and being a creative quote,
creative genius.
So a on that night, what, what,
what was going through your
head or maybe put another way,
how do you solve these problems?
What's your approach to solving these
kinds of problems with the line between
success and failure?
It seems to be pretty thin.
That's a good question.
Well, first of all, that's,
that's a nice of Justin to say that I
think I would have been maybe 21 years old
then and not very experienced at
programming. But as with, um, uh,
with everything in a startup, you're,
you're sort of racing against the clock.
And so our plan was the second we had
this live streaming camera backpack up and
running, we're Justin could wear it and
no matter where he went in the city,
it would be streaming live video.
And this is even before the iPhones,
this is like hard to do back then
we would launch.
And so we thought we were there and,
and the backpack was working and then
we send out all the emails, launch the,
launch the company and do the
press thing. And then, you know,
we weren't quite actually there. And
then, um, we thought, oh well, you know,
they're not going to announce it until
maybe 10:00 AM the next morning and it's,
I don't know, it's 5:00 PM now.
So how many hours do we have left?
What is that like, you know,
17 hours to go. And uh,
and that was,
that was going to be fine
was a problem I have is did you
understand what could possibly be like how
complicated was the system at that point?
It was,
it was pretty messy.
So to get a live video feed that looked
decent working from anywhere in San
Francisco,
I put together this system where we
had like three or four cell phone data
modems and they were like,
we take the video stream and s you know,
sort of sprayed across these three or
four modems and then try to catch all the
packets on the other side, you know,
with unreliable cell phone networks.
Pretty low level networking. Yeah.
And putting these like, you know,
sort of protocols on top of all that to
to reassemble and reorder the packets
and have time buffers and error correction
and all that kind of stuff. And um,
the, the night before
it was just static. He,
every once in a while the image would,
would go staticky and there would be
this horrible like screeching audio noise
because the audio was also corrupted and
this would happen like every five to 10
minutes or so. And it was a
really off putting to the viewers.
How do you tackle that
problem? What was the, uh,
he just freaking out behind a computer.
There's the word.
Are there other other folks working on
this problem that we behind a white board
where you doing? Uh, uh,
there's a,
there's a little hill,
he has a little lonely because there's
four of us working on the company and I
only two people really wrote code and
Emmett wrote the website in the chat
system and I wrote the software for this
video streaming device in video server.
And so I, you know, it was my sole
responsibility to figure that out. Yeah.
And I think, I think it's those, you
know, setting, setting deadlines,
trying to move quickly and everything
were where you're in that moment of
intense pressure that sometimes people
do their best and most interesting work.
And so even though that
was a terrible moment,
I look back on it fondly
cause that's like, you know,
that's one of those character
defining moments. I think.
So in a 2013 October you
founded cruise automation.
Yeah. So progressing forward, uh,
another exception successful company was
acquired by GM and 16 for $1 billion.
But uh, in October of 2013,
what was on your mind?
What was the plan?
How does one seriously start to
tackle one of the hardest robotics,
most important,
impactful robotics problems of our age
after going through
twitch? Twitch was, was,
and is today pretty successful.
But the um,
the work was, the result was
entertainment mostly like the,
the better the product was, the more we
would entertain people and then, you know,
make money on them ad revenues
and other things. And that was,
it was a good thing. It felt, it felt good
to entertain people, but I figured like,
you know,
what is really the point of becoming a
really good engineer and developing the
skills other than, you
know, my own enjoyment.
And I realized I wanted something that
scratched more of an existential itch,
like something that truly matters.
And so I basically made this
list of requirements for a new,
if I was going to do another company and
the one thing I knew in the back of my
head that twitch took like eight
years to become successful.
And so whatever I do, I better
be willing to commit, you know,
at least 10 years to something.
And when you think about
things from that perspective,
you certainly I think raise the bar on
what you choose to work on. So for me,
the three things where it had to be
something where the technology itself
determines the success of the product,
like hard,
really juicy technology problems
because that's what motivates me.
And then it had to have a direct and
positive impact on society in some way.
So an example would be like you know,
healthcare self driving
cars cause they save lives.
Other things where there's a clear
connection to somehow improving other
people's lives.
And the last one is it had to be a big
business because for the positive impact
to matter,
it's got to be a large scale scale.
And as thinking about that
for a while and I made like a,
I tried writing at Gmail clone and looked
at some other ideas and then it just
sort of light bulb went
off like self driving cars.
Like that was the most fun I'd ever
had in college. Working on that.
And like well what's the state of the
technology has been 10 years, maybe,
maybe times have changed. And maybe
now is the time to make this work.
And I poked around and looked at,
the only other thing out there really
at the time was the Google self driving
car project. And I thought surely
there's a way to, you know,
have an entrepreneurial mindset and
sort of solve the minimum viable product
here. And so I, I just took the plunge
right then and there and said this,
this is something I know
I can commit 10 years too.
It's the probably the greatest applied
AI problem of our generation and if it
works, it's going to be both
a huge business and therefore
like probably the most
positive impact I can
possibly have on the world.
So after that light bulb went off,
I went all in on cruise
immediately and got to work.
Did you have an idea how
to solve this problem?
Which aspects of the problem to solve?
You know,
s slowly we just had to
Oliver for voyage here,
slow moving a retirement communities,
uh, urban driving highway driving.
Did you have,
did you have a vision of the city
of the future or you know, uh,
the transportation is largely automated,
that kind of thing?
Or was it sort of more fuzzy
and gray area than that?
My analysis of the situation is
that Google is putting a lot,
it had been putting a lot
of money into that project,
had a lot more resources and so,
and they still hadn't cracked the fully
driverless car. You know, this is 20, 20,
uh, 13 I guess. So I thought, what,
what can I do to sort of go from zero to,
you know,
significant scale so I can
actually solve the real problem,
which is the driverless cars. And
I thought, here's the strategy.
We'll start by doing a really simple
or solving a really simple problem that
creates value for people.
So eventually ended up deciding
on automating highway driving,
which is relatively more straightforward.
As long as there's a backup driver there
and I'll, you know, the go to market,
we'll be able to retrofit people's cars
and just sell these products directly.
And the idea was we'll take
all the revenue and profits
from that and use it to
do the assessor will reinvest
that in research for doing fully,
fully driverless cars.
And that was the plan.
The only thing that really changed
along the way between then and now is we
never really launched the first product.
We had enough interest from investors
in enough of a signal that this was
something that we should
be working on that, um,
after about a year of working on the
highway autopilot, we had it working,
you know, on a prototype stage, but we
just completely abandoned that and said,
we're going to go all in on
driverless cars. Now is the time. Um,
can't think of anything that's more
exciting and if it works more impactful,
so we're just going to go for it. The
idea of retrofit is kind of interesting.
Yeah. A of being able to,
it's how you choose scale.
It's really interesting ideas.
It's something that's still in the back
of your mind as a possibility and not at
all.
I've come full circle on that one after
trying to build a retrofit product and
I'll touch on some of the complexities
of that and then also having been inside
an OEM and seeing how things work and
how a vehicle is developed and validated.
When it comes to
something that has safety,
critical implications like
controlling the steering and you know,
other controlling puts on your car,
it's pretty hard to get there with
with a retrofit or, or if you did,
even if you did it,
it creates a whole bunch
of new complications around
liability or how did you
truly validate that or you know,
something in the base vehicle fails
and causes your system to fail.
Who's fault is it?
Or if the car's antilock brake systems
or other things kick in or the software
has been,
it's different in one version of the
car you retrofit versus another and you
don't know because the manufacturer
has updated it behind the scenes.
There's basically an infinite list of
long tail issues that can get you and if
you're dealing with the safety critical
product, that's not really acceptable.
That's a really convincing summary
of why this really challenging,
but I didn't know that at the time.
So we tried it anyway.
But as a pitch also at the
time it's a really strong one.
This is how you achieve scale and
that's how you beat the current, the,
the leader at the time of Google
or the only one in the market.
The other big problem we ran into,
which is perhaps the biggest problem
from a business model perspective is um,
we had kind of assumed that we started
with an Audi s four as the vehicle.
We retrofitted with this highway driving
capability and we had kind of assumed
that if we just knock out like three
make and models of vehicle that'll cover
like 80% of the San Francisco market
doesn't everyone, their drive, I dunno,
a BMW or Honda civic or
one of these three cars.
And then we surveyed our users when we
found out that it's all over the place,
we would get even a decent number of
units sold. We'd have to support like,
you know,
20 or 50 different models and each one
is a little butterfly that takes time and
effort to maintain,
you know,
that retrofit integration and
custom hardware and all this.
So is it is a tough business.
So GM manufactures and sells
over 9 million cars a year
and what you with crews
are trying to do some of the most cutting
edge innovation in terms of applying
AI and says how do those,
we've talked about it a little bit before,
but it's also just fascinating to me. We
work a lot of automakers, uh, you know,
the difference between the gap between
Detroit and Silicon Valley, let's say,
just to be sort of poetic about it,
I guess. How do you close that gap?
How do you take GM into the future
where a large part of the fleet will be
autonomous?
Perhaps?
I want to start by acknowledging that
that GM is made up of tens of thousands of
really brilliant, motivated people who
want to be a part of the future. And uh,
so it's,
it's pretty fun to work with them.
The attitude inside a car company
like that is, you know, uh,
embracing this transformation and
change rather than fearing it.
And I think that's a testament to the
leadership at GM and that's fallen all the
way through to,
to everyone you talk to even the people
in the assembly plants working on these
cars. Right? So that's really great.
So that starting from that
position makes it a lot easier.
So then when the,
the people in San Francisco at cruise
interact with the people at GM,
at least we have this
common set of values,
which is that we really want this stuff
to work because we think it's important
and we think it's the future.
That's not to say, you know,
those two cultures don't clash. They
absolutely do. There's different,
different sort of value systems.
Like in a car company,
the thing that gets you promoted and,
and sort of the reward system
is following the processes,
delivering the, the, the
program on time and on budget.
So any sort of risk taking is discouraged
in many ways because if a program is
late or if you shut down the
plant for a day, it's, you know,
you can count the millions of dollars
that burned by pretty quickly.
Whereas I think in, uh, uh, most
silicon valley companies and, and in,
in, in cruise and the
methodology we were employing,
especially around the
time of the acquisition,
the reward structure is about trying to
solve these complex problems in any way,
shape or form or coming up with
crazy ideas that, you know,
90% of them won't work. And, uh, and so,
so meshing that culture of sort of
continuous improvement and experimentation
with one where everything needs to be,
you know,
rigorously defined up front
so that you never slip a,
a deadline or miss a budget was a
pretty big challenge in that we're,
we're over three years in now, uh,
after the acquisition. And I'd say like,
you know,
the investment we made in figuring out
how to work together successfully and who
should do what and a how we bridge the
gaps between these very different systems
and way of doing engineering work is
now one of our greatest assets because I
think we have this really powerful thing.
But for awhile it was
both boogeyman crews were,
were very steep on the learning curve.
Yes. I'm sure it was very stressful.
It's really important work cause that's,
that's how to revolutionize
the transportation.
It really to revolutionize any system.
You know,
you look at the healthcare system
or you look at the legal system.
I have people like Laura has
come up to me all the time,
like everything they're working on,
it can easily be automated,
but then that's not a good feeling.
Yeah. That was not a good feeling.
But also there is no way to
automate because the, the,
the entire infrastructure
is really, uh, you know,
based is older and it
moves very slowly and so,
so how do you close the gap between
I haven't, how can I replace?
Of course lawyers don't want
to be replaced with an APP,
but you could replace a lot of aspect
when most of the data's still on paper.
And so the same thing was with automotive.
I mean,
it's fundamentally software.
So it's basically hiring
software engineers is thinking
a software world. I mean,
I'm pretty sure nobody in silicon valley,
he's ever hit a deadline. And then, uh,
on, on Janice, probably true. Yeah.
And Geoscience probably the opposite.
So that's,
that culture gap is really fascinating.
So you're optimistic
about the future of that?
Yeah, I mean, from what I've seen,
uh, it's impressive. And I think like,
especially in Silicon Valley, it's easy
to write off building cars because,
you know,
people had been doing that for over
a hundred years now in this country.
And so it seems like
that's a solved problem,
but that doesn't mean it's
an easy problem. And, uh,
I think it would be easy to sort of
overlook that and think that, you know,
where Silicon Valley engineers,
we can solve any problem,
you know, building a car,
it's been done, therefore it's,
you know, it's, it's, it's not a,
it's not a real engineering challenge.
But after having seen just the sheer
scale and magnitude and industrialization
that occurs inside of an
automotive assembly plant,
that is a lot of work that I am very
glad that we don't have to reinvent, um,
to make self driving cars work.
And so to have partners who've
done that for a hundred years now,
these great processes and this huge
infrastructure and supply base that we can
tap into is just remarkable
because the scope
and surface area of,
of the problem of deploying fleets of
self driving cars is so large that we're
constantly looking for ways to do less
so we can focus on the things that really
matter more. And if we had to figure
out how to build and assemble and
yeah, build the cars themselves. I
mean we work closely with Jim on that,
but if we had to develop all that
capability in house as well, you know,
that that would just make, make the
problem really intractable. I think so,
yeah.
Just like your first
and tree, the Mit Darpa challenge when
there was, what the motor that failed,
somebody that knows what they're
doing with a motor did it,
I would have been nice if we
can get focus on the software,
not the hardware platform. Yeah. Right.
So, uh, from your perspective now,
you know,
there's so many ways that autonomous
vehicles can impact society in the next
year, five years, 10 years.
What do you think is the
biggest opportunity to make
money in autonomous driving?
So sort of make it a financially
viable thing in the near term.
What do you think would be
the biggest impact there?
Well,
the things that,
that drive the economics for fleets of
self driving cars are, there's sort of a,
a handful of variables. One is, you know,
the cost to build the vehicle itself. So
the material costs, how many, you know,
what's the cost of all your sensors?
Plus the cost of the vehicle and every,
all the other components on it. Another
one is the lifetime of the vehicle.
It's very different if your vehicle drives
a hundred thousand miles and then it
falls apart versus you know, 2
million. Right. And then, you know,
if you have a fleet,
it's kind of like an airplane where,
or a airline where once you produce the
vehicle you want it to be in operation
as many hours a day as possible producing
revenue. And then, uh, you know,
the other piece of that is how
are you generating revenue?
And I think that's kind
of what you're asking.
And I think the obvious things today are,
you know,
the ride sharing business because that's
pretty clear that there's demand for
that.
There's existing markets you can
tap into and large urban and areas,
that kind of thing. Yeah. Yeah. And, and,
and I think that there are some real
benefits to having cars without drivers
compared to sort of the status quo for
people who use ride share services today.
You know, you get privacy consistency,
hopefully you significant improve safety,
all these benefits versus the
current product, but it's a, it's a,
it's a crowded market. And then, uh,
other opportunities which you've seen
a lot of activity in the last really in
the last six to 12 months
is, uh, you know, delivery,
whether that's parcels and
packages, uh, food or groceries.
Um, those are all sort of, I
think, opportunities that are,
that are pretty ripe for these,
you know,
once you have this core technology,
which is the fleet of autonomous vehicles,
there's all sorts of different business
opportunities you can build on top of
that. But I think the
important thing of, of course,
is that there's zero
monetization opportunity until
you actually have that fleet
of very capable of
driverless cars that are,
that are as good or better than humans.
And that's
sort of where the entire industry is sort
of in this holding pattern right now.
Yeah. They're trying to do their
baseline. So, but you said sort of relied,
not reliability, consistency.
It's kind of interesting.
I think I heard you say somewhere,
I'm not sure if that's what you meant,
but you know,
I can imagine a situation where you
would get an autonomous vehicle and uh,
you know,
when you get into an Uber or Lyft,
you don't get to choose the driver in a
sense that you don't get to choose the
personality of the driving.
Do you think there's, uh,
there's room to define the
personality of the car,
the way it drives you in terms
of aggressiveness for example,
in terms of sort of pushing the bar,
the,
one of the biggest challenges
in autonomous driving is the,
is the trade off between sort of safety
and assertiveness and do you think
there's any room for the human
to take a role in that decision?
So to accept some of the liability?
I guess
I wouldn't have said no.
I'd say within reasonable bounds,
as in we're not going to,
I think it'd be higher than likely we'd
expose any knob that would let you,
you know, significantly increase
senior safety risk. I think that's,
that's just not something
we'd be willing to do.
But I think driving style or like,
you know,
are you going to relax the comfort
constraints slightly or things like that.
All of those things make sense in our
plausible, I see all those as you know,
nice optimizations.
Once again we get the core problem
solved and these fleets out there.
But the other thing we've sort of observed
is that you have this intuition that
if you sort of slam your foot on the gas
right after the light turns green and
aggressively accelerate,
you're going to get there faster.
But the actual impact of
doing that is pretty small.
You feel like you're getting there faster,
but so that it's the same would be true
for Avs. Even if they don't slam there,
you know, the pedal to the floor
when the light turns green,
they're going to get you there within,
you know,
if it's a 15 minute trip within 30 seconds
of what you would have done otherwise
if you are going really aggressively.
So I think there's this sort of
self deception that, that uh,
my aggressive driving style
is getting me there faster.
Well, so that's, you know,
some of the things I study,
some of the things I'm fascinated
by the psychology of that.
I don't think it matters. That
doesn't get you there faster. It's,
it's the emotional release.
Driving is a place being etc. Car,
somebody said it's like the real world
version of being a troll as he have this
protection,
this mineral protection and you're
able to sort of yell at the world like
release your anger,
whatever is.
But so there's an element of that that
I think autonomous vehicles will also
have to s you know, giving an outlet to
people, but it doesn't have to be through,
through, through driving or honking
or, so there might be other outlets,
but I think to just sort of even just
put that aside, the baseline is really,
you know, that's the focus. That's
the thing you need to solve.
And then the fund human
things can be solved after.
But so from the baseline of just solving
antonymous driving and you're working
in San Francisco, one of the more
difficult cities to operate in, what is,
what is the,
in your view currently the hardest aspect
of autonomous driving is negotiated
with pedestrians?
Is it a edge cases of perception?
Is it planning? Is there a mechanical
engineering's it data fleet stuff?
I w w what are your
thoughts on the challenge,
the more challenging aspects there?
That's a good, that's a good question. I
think before we, before we go to that too,
I just want to,
I liked what you said about the psychology
aspect of this because I think one
observation I've made is,
I think I read somewhere that I think
it's maybe Americans on average spent,
you know, over an hour, a day on
social media, like staring at Facebook.
And so that's just, you know, 60 minutes
of your life, you're not getting back.
It's probably not super productive. And
so that's 3,600 seconds. Right. And,
uh, that's, that's tiny. You know,
it's a lot of time you're giving up.
And if you compare that to people
being on road, if another vehicle,
whether it's a human driver
or autonomous vehicle,
delays them by even three seconds right
there laying in on the horn. You know,
even though that's, that's, you
know, one, 1000th of the time,
they waste looking at Facebook every day.
So there's,
there's definitely some psychology
aspects of this I think that are pretty
interesting.
Road rage in general.
And then the question of course is if
everyone is in self driving cars to even
notice these three second delays anymore
cause they're doing other things or
reading or working or just
talking to each other.
So it'll be interesting to see where
that goes in a certain aspect. People,
people need to be distracted
by something entertaining,
something useful inside the car so they
don't pay attention to the external
world.
And then the,
and then they can take whatever
psychology and bring it back to Twitter.
And the focus on that as opposed
to sort of interacting, uh,
is sort of putting the motion out
there into the world. So it's a,
it's an interesting problem,
but baseline autonomy,
I guess you could say self driving cars,
you know,
at scale we'll lower the collective
blood pressure of society,
probably buy a couple of points
without all that road rage and stress.
So that's a good, good externality. Um,
so back to your question about
the technology and the, the,
I guess the biggest problems,
and I have a hard time answering
that question because you know,
we've been at this like specifically
focusing on driverless cars and all the
technology needed to enable that for a
little over four and a half years now.
And even a year or two in,
I felt like we had
completed the functionality needed to
get someone from point a to point B as in
if we need to do a left turn maneuver or
if we need to drive around, uh, you know,
double parked vehicle into oncoming
traffic or navigate through construction
zones. The, the scaffolding
and the building blocks were,
was there pretty early on.
And so the challenge is not any one
scenario or situation for which we fail at
100% of those. It's more, you know,
we're benchmarking against a pretty
good or pretty high standard,
which is human driving.
All things considered.
Humans are excellent at handling edge
cases and unexpected scenarios where
computers are the opposite.
And so beating that that a baseline
set by humans is the challenge.
And so what we've been doing for
quite some time now is basically
it's this continuous improvement process
where we find sort of the, the most, um,
you know, uncomfortable or,
or the things that that, um,
could lead to a, uh, a safety issue,
other things, all these events.
And then we sort of categorize them and,
uh,
rework parts of our system to
make incremental improvements
and do that over and
over and over again.
And we just see sort of the overall
performance of the system. You know,
actually increasing at a pretty
steady clip. But there's no one thing,
there's actually like thousands of
little things and just like polishing
functionality and making sure that
it handles, you know, every Vr,
every version and possible permutation
of a situation by either applying more
deep learning systems or
just by, uh, you know,
adding more test coverage or new
scenarios that, that we develop against.
And just grinding on that.
It's, we're sort of in the,
the unsexy phase of development right now,
which is doing the real engineering work
that it takes to go from prototype to
production.
You're basically scaling the,
the grinding.
So sort of taking seriously
that the process of a,
all those edge cases,
both with human experts in machine
learning methods to, to cover,
to cover all of those situations.
Yeah. And the exciting thing for me is
I don't think that grinding ever stops,
right? Because there's a
moment in time where you,
you've crossed that threshold of, of
human performance and become superhuman,
but there's no reason,
there's no first principles reason that
ab capability will tap out anywhere near
humans. Like there's no reason it couldn't
be 20 times better, whether that's,
you know,
just better driving or safer driving
and more comfortable driving or even a
thousand times better given enough time.
And we intend to basically chase that,
you know,
forever
to build the best possible product better
and better and better and always new
edge cases come up and you experiences so,
and you want to automate that
process as much as possible.
So what do you think
in general in society,
when do you think we may have hundreds
of thousands of fully autonomous vehicles
driving around? So first of all,
predictions, nobody knows the future.
You're a part of the leading people trying
to define that future. But even then,
you still don't know. But if you think
about a hundreds of thousands of vehicles,
so a significant fraction of vehicles
in major cities that are autonomous.
Do you think [inaudible] with Rodney
Brooks who is 2050 and beyond?
Or are you more
with Ilan Musk who is,
we should have had that two years ago.
Well, I mean, I don't mean
to have two years ago,
but we're not there yet.
So,
I guess the way I would
think about that is let's,
let's flip that question around.
So what would prevent you to reach
hundreds of thousands of vehicles?
And that's a good, that's a good
rephrasing it. Yeah. So the,
I'd say that it seems the consensus
among the people developing self driving
cars today is to sort of start with
some form of an easier environment.
Whether it means you know,
lacking inclement weather or you know,
mostly sunny or whatever it is,
and then add add capability for
more complex situations over time.
And so if you're only able to deploy
in areas that that meets sort of your
criteria or that the current domain,
you know, operating domain of,
of the software you developed a,
that may put a cap on how many
cities you could deploy in,
but then as those restrictions
start to fall away,
like maybe you add a capability to drive
really well and safely and heavy rain
or snow,
you know,
that that probably opens up the market
by two or two or three fold in terms of
the cities you can expand into and so on.
And so the real question is, you know,
I know today if we wanted to,
we could produce that,
that many autonomous vehicles,
but we wouldn't be able to make use of
all of them yet cause we would sort of
saturate the demand in the cities in
which we would want to operate initially.
So if I were to guess like what the
timeline is for those things falling away
and reaching hundreds of
thousands of vehicles,
maybe a range is, but I would say less
than five years. That's the five years.
Yeah. And of course you're
working hard to make that happen.
So you started two companies that were
eventually acquired for each $4 billion.
So you're pretty good person to ask.
What does it take to build
a successful startup?
Hmm. I think, uh, there's, there's sort
of survivor bias here a little bit,
but I can try to find some common threads
for the, the things that worked for me,
which is, you know, I, in,
in both of these companies,
it was really passionate about the core
technology. I actually like, you know,
lay awake at night thinking about
these problems and how to solve them.
And I think that's helpful
because when you start a business,
there are that like to this day
they're are these crazy ups and downs.
Like one day you think the
business is just on your,
you're just on top of the
world and unstoppable and
the next day you think, okay,
this is all gonna end.
You know, it's, it's just,
it's just gone south and it's going
to be over tomorrow. Um, and uh,
and so I think like having a true passion
that you can fall back on and knowing
that you would be doing it even
if you weren't getting paid for,
it helps you weather those tough times.
So that's one thing.
I think the other one is
really good people.
So I've always been surrounded by
really good co founders that are logical
thinkers are always pushing their limits
and have very high levels of integrity.
So that's Dan Kahn and my current company
and actually his brother and a couple
other guys for Justin TV and twitch.
And then I think the last thing is
just, uh, I guess persistence
or perseverance like and,
and that that can apply to
sticking to sort of, uh,
or having conviction around the original
premise of your idea and sticking
around to do all the,
you know,
the unsexy work to actually make it come
to fruition, including dealing with,
you know, well, whatever it is
that you're not passionate about,
whether that's finance or, or HR
or, or operations or those things.
It as long as you are grinding away and
working towards that North Star for your
business,
whatever it is,
and you don't give up and you're
making progress every day,
it seems like eventually
we'll end up in a good place.
And the only things that can
slow you down are, you know,
running out of money or I suppose
your competitors destroying you.
But I think most of the time it's people
giving upper or somehow destroying
things themselves rather than being beaten
by their competition are running out
of money.
Yeah. If you never quit,
eventually you'll arrive.
So a more concise version
of what I was trying to say
that you went to y Combinator out twice.
Yeah.
What do you think in a quick question,
do you think is the best way to raise
funds in the early days or not just funds
but just the community
develop your idea and so on.
Can you do it solo or maybe with
a cofounder with Zach self funded?
Do you think y Combinator is good,
is a good to do VC route?
Is there no right answer or was there
from the y Combinator experience something
that you could take away that
that was the right path to take?
There's no one size fits all answer,
but if your ambition I think is to,
you see how big you can make something or,
or,
or rapidly expand and capture market
or solve a problem or whatever it is,
then then you know, going to venture
background is probably a good approach.
So that, so that capital doesn't
become your primary constraint.
Y Combinator I love because
it puts you in this, uh,
sort of competitive environment while
you're where you're surrounded by,
you know, the top maybe 1% of other
really highly motivated, you know,
peers who are in the same,
same place and that, uh,
that environment I think just
breeds, breeds success, right?
If you're surrounded by really brilliant,
hardworking people,
you're going to feel sort of compelled
or inspired to to try to emulate them or
beat them. And uh, so even though I had
done it once before and I felt like,
yeah, I'm pretty self motivated,
I thought like, I look,
this is going to be a hard problem.
I can use all the help I can get.
So surrounding myself with
other entrepreneurs is going
to make me work a little
bit harder or push a little harder than
it's worth it and society. Why? Why?
I did it for example,
the second time,
let's uh,
let's go philosophical existential.
If you go back and do something
differently in your life starting in high
school,
then MIT leaving MIT,
you could have gone the phd
route doing the startup,
going to see about a startup in California
and you or maybe some aspects of
fundraising. Is there something
you regret, something,
well not necessarily grab,
but if you go back good to differently.
I think I've made a lot of
mistakes. Like, you know,
pretty much everything you can screw up.
I think I've screwed up at least once,
but I, you know, I don't regret those
things. I think it's, it's hard to,
hard to look back on things even if
they didn't go well and call it a regret
because hopefully,
you know,
it took away some new knowledge
or learning from that. So
I would say there, there was a
period, yeah. Uh, the closest
I can, I can come to us.
There was a period, um, in, in Justin
TV I think after seven years where,
you know, the, the company was going one
direction, which is towards twitch, uh,
in video gaming. I'm not a video gamer.
I don't really even use twitch at all.
And I was still working on
the core technology there,
but my heart was no longer in it because
the business that we were creating was
not something that I was
personally passionate about.
It didn't meet your bar of
existential impact. Yeah.
And I'd say I probably spent an extra
year or two working on that and uh,
and I'd say like I would have just
tried to do something different sooner.
Cause those were, those were two
years where I felt like, um, you know,
from this philosophical or
existential thing, I just,
I just felt something was missing.
And so I, I would've, I would've,
if I could look back now and tell myself,
it's like I would have said exactly that.
Like,
you're not getting any meeting out of your
work personally right now. You should,
you should find a way to change that.
And that's part of the pitch I used to
basically everyone who joins cruise today,
it's like, Hey, you've got
that now by coming here. Well,
maybe you need the two years of that
existential dread to develop the feeling
that ultimately it was the fire that
create a cruise. So you never know.
You can't be a good theory.
Yeah. So last question,
what does 2018 holds for Cruz after this?
I guess we're going to go
and talk to your class,
but one of the big things is going
from prototype to production, uh,
for autonomous cars.
And what does that mean?
What's that look like in 2019 for us is,
is the year that we try to cross over
that threshold and reach, you know,
superhuman level of performance to some
degree with the software and have all
the other of the thousands
of little building blocks
in place to, to launch. Um,
you know, our, our first
commercial product. So that's,
that's what's in store for us,
are in the,
in store for us and we've
got a lot of work to do.
We've got a lot of brilliant
people working on it. So
it's, it's all up to us now.
Yeah.
From Charlie Miller and Chris Val's like,
people have crossed paths with it
sounds like given an amazing team.
So, um, like I said, it's one of the most,
I think one of the most important
problems in artificial intelligence of the
century will be one of the most defining,
the super exciting that you work on it.
And, uh, the bus to look at 2018.
I'm really excited to see what
Cruz comes up with. Thank you.
Thanks for having me today.
Nice call.